♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR HAD STRONG WORDS ABOUT
ROBERT MUELLER'S UPCOMING
TESTIMONY, QUESTIONING WHY THE
DEMOCRATS ARE EVEN HOLDING A
HEARING WITH A FORMER SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> IT SEEMS TO ME THE ONLY
REASON FOR DOING THAT IS TO
CREATE SOME KIND OF PUBLIC
SPECTACLE.
IF BOB DECIDES HE DOESN'T WANT
TO BE SUBJECT TO THAT, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WAS
CERTAINLY BACK AND PRAYED
>> Sean: TONIGHT CONGRESSMAN
PETER KING, NEW YORK, HIS
WARNING, "SEVERE, SERIOUS ABUSES
BY THE FBI AND CIA IN THE RUSH
OF PROBE ARE GOING TO COME OUT."
WE'VE BEEN SAYING THAT FOR TWO
PLUS YEARS.
JOINING US NOW, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER CONGRESSMAN
TREY GOWDY.
ONE THING I'VE ALWAYS LIKED
ABOUT YOU, WHEN YOU DIG IN, GOD
HELP WHOEVER IS ON THE OTHER
SIDE, YOU AS A PROSECUTOR, YOU
NEVER LOST A CASE, CORRECT?
>> I'VE NEVER WON ONE WITH MY
WIFE.
SO I AM OKAY IN THE COURTROOM
HAVEN'T DONE WELL AT HOME.
>> Sean: [LAUGHS]
THAT'S OKAY.
THAT IS A GOOD LINE.
>> 30 YEARS WORTH OF LOSSES.
>> Sean: I WANT YOU IN THESE
HEARINGS HAVE TIMES THAT I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE CAPABLE OF.
NOW TRY TO BRING US INTO WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING IN YOUR VIEW.
YOU HAVE THE INSPECTOR GENERAL,
YOU HAVE THE COMMENTS OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, YOU HAVE
MUELLER TESTIFYING, WHICH I
THINK WILL BACKFIRE, THEN YOU
HAVE DURHAM, STEELE, ALL THESE
PEOPLE COMING OUT LAST MINUTE ON
FISA ABUSE, WHAT DO YOU
HAPPENING?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
I THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
THE HEARING NEXT WEEK WITH
MUELLER WILL BE A CARNIVAL.
IT WILL BE A FREAK SHOW.
THINK BACK TO MARCH OF 2017,
SEAN, WHEN DEVIN NUNES HAD A
PUBLIC HEARING -- I LOVE HIM --
BUT PUBLIC HEARINGS DON'T TURN
OUT WELL, NO MATTER WHO CALLS
THEM.
HE CALLED A PUBLIC HEARING, HOW
JIM COMEY, 100 TIMES, THE
WITNESS SAID, "I CANNOT ANSWER
THAT QUESTION IN THIS FORM."
YOU THINK THE MEDIA WITH A COME
OF THAT WAS A WASTE OF
EVERYBODY'S TIME, DON'T EVER DO
THAT AGAIN.
THEY LOVE IT.
THEY LOVE IT BECAUSE WHAT
ADAM SCHIFF AND ERIC SWALWELL
AND THE OTHERS DID IS READ
NEWSPAPER ARTICLES THAT CONTAIN
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ONLY FOR
THE REDNESS
the redness
, THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
SAY, I CANNOT COMMENT ON THE
SETTING.
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
NEXT WEEK.
MUELLER'S REPORT IS OUT.
HE'S NOT GOING TO DEVIATE FROM
THE FOUR CORNERS OF THAT ARE
BARRED.
THAT NOT KEEP HOUSE DEMOCRATS --
THE FOCUS WILL BE ON THE
QUESTION, NOT THE ANSWER.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS GOING
ON, I LOVE PETER KING, BUT
REPUBLICANS HAVE GOT TO GET
BETTER AT NOT ALWAYS PROMISING
WHAT IS GETTING READY TO COME.
LOOK AT WHAT ALREADY EXISTS!
LOOK AT WHAT HOROWITZ FOUND!
STRZOK AND PAID WITH A HISTORIC
LEVEL OF BIAS.
YOU HAVE A DOSSIER THAT WAS USED
IN ACCORD PLEADED THAT WAS NOT
VERIFIED.
YOU HAVE STEELE, WHO WAS
DEFROCKED AS A SOURCE BUT YET
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO AS THE WORLD'S PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, AND YOU
HAVE A DOJ SENIOR OFFICIAL IN
BRUCE OHR WHO WAS IN THE CHAIN
OF EVIDENCE FROM FUSION GPS TO
THE DOJ.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PROMISE
ANYTHING ELSE!
THAT OUGHT TO BE ENOUGH FOR MY
FELLOW CITIZENS TO SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, SOMETHING AIN'T RIGHT!
>> Sean: WHO AUTHORED THE
MUELLER REPORT, WHEN DID HE KNOW
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION?
HOW IS THAT HE HAD TIME TO THE
TAXICAB ITALIANS, THE PROSECUTOR
WILL DISCRETION IS USED
EVERY DAY.
THE TAXICAB MEDALLIONS, FARA
ABUSE, LOAN APPLICATIONS, TAXES,
HOW DID HE NOT HAVE TIME FOR A
DIRTY DOSSIER?
I WOULD LIKE THAT QUESTION
ANSWERED.
FROM RUSSIA.
>> I THINK WHAT IS GOING TO SAY
ON THAT, JOHN RATCLIFFE AND I
WERE DISCUSSING IT OVER THE
WEEKEND, I THINK WHAT HE'S GOING
TO SAY, THAT IS NOT WHAT
ROD ROSENSTEIN ASKED ME TO DO.
I DID WHAT THE ACTING DOJ AGE HE
ASKED ME TO DO, WHICH IS LOOK AT
--DASH GO BACK TO ROD'S MEMO.
WHAT DID RUSSIA DO IN 2016?
THEN A SPECIFIC REFERENCE TO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I THINK THAT IS MUELLER'S OUT.
HIS OUT ON WHEN DID YOU GO THERE
WAS NO COLLUSION, WHEN WE
INTERVIEW THE LAST WITNESS.
SO MUELLER DOES NOT WANT TO
COME.
HE DOES NOT WANT TO COME BECAUSE
HE DOES NOT WANT TO DEVIATE FROM
HIS REPORT.
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET OUR
THESE INCENDIARY QUESTIONS ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION AND IMPEACHMENT.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO LEARN
ANYTHING THAT YOU DON'T ALREADY
KNOW.
IT'S JUST GOING TO BE GREAT FOR
PEOPLE --
>> Sean: HE'S GOING TO HAVE A
HARD TIME ANSWERING HOW HE HAD
ONE CANDIDATE PAID FOR RUSSIAN
LIES AND IT BECAME THE BASIS OF
A FISA WARRANT.
HOW DOES NOT BECOME AN INFLUENCE
ON THE 2016 ELECTION?
BUT TAXICAB MEDALLIONS DEAD?
I WOULD LIKE AN ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION.
>> HELP SOMEBODY CAN GET THAT
ASKED AND ANSWERED IN 5 MINUTES.
5 MINUTES IS NOT MUCH TO UNLOCK
THE MYSTERIES OF THE WORLD.
>> Sean: BOB MUELLER'S NINE
AND A HALF MINUTES WAS NOT
EXACTLY STELLAR.
I THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
GRACIOUSLY BAILED HIM OUT WITH A
JOINT STATEMENT.
THAT IS A GUESS ON MY PART.
>> I HOPE I'M WRONG.
I JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS GOING
TO HELP ANYBODY FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU'RE PRETTY